It takes around two hours to boil an ostrich
egg.
There are castles for sale in France that
are cheaper than two bedroom apartments in
Australia.
Chopping wood increases testosterone production
by 46.8%, which is 17% higher than most competitive
sports.
In the early 1900s a woman named Dorothy Eady
from London made substantial contributions
to Egyptology after she hit her head as a
toddler and claimed to have unlocked a past
life as a priestess in Ancient Egypt.
Ground up red squirrel testicles injected
into the bloodstream were once considered
to be the secret to eternal youth by Dr. Horace
Emmett.
One year after he announced this at a Cambridge
lecture, touting his newfound virility as
proof, he died of a cerebral haemorrhage.
The longest place name in the world is a hill
in New Zealand called this: Taumatawhakatangihangakoauauotamateaturipukakapikimaungahoronukupoka-wenuakitanatahu.
Walt Disney used many dummy corporations to
purchase the massive amounts of land needed
for Disney World.
But his plan was publicised and whilst his
first acres were purchased for around $80,
the last ones were over $80,000 each.
In Germany there are fake bus stops outside
many nursing homes to prevent senior citizens
with Alzheimers from wandering off.
There is a city called Rome on every continent.
Slugs have four noses.
If two pieces of metal with a similar composition,
such as two pieces of copper, touch in space
they instantly become one.
This process is known as cold welding.
According to a study performed by Pew Research
in 2010, atheists knew more in general about
different religions than religious people
did.
With Jews coming in a close second and Mormons
in third place.
The male scorpion fly gets other males to
bring him food by imitating a female fly.
A crocodile cannot stick out its tongue.
One of the early names for Iceland was Snowland,
another was Butterland.
In March 2014, an unnamed British sniper in
Afghanistan killed six insurgents with a single
bullet.
He hit the target from 850 metres away, which
was a trigger switch of a suicide bomber,
whose device then exploded.
Thereby preventing a major attack by the Taliban.